[Music]
this gun was made at someone's home
assembled with 3d printed parts the
designs for it are not buried on the
dark web
but are easily found online we've seen
extremists share these designs we've
seen extremists try to construct 3d
printed guns and all that's missing
really is the next step of someone
completing an attack with a 3d printed
gun and it's as if we're witnessing
the revealing of this threat in slow
motion sky news has found social media
sites such as instagram youtube and
twitter are being used to help people
download files for 3d printable guns and
these guns are turning up in britain
this was recovered in september 2021
from a borough in northeast london but
how much of a threat are they
[Music]
so what do we have today we got a
special project
it is the bubble gun legal in the u.s an
online community has sprung up
making designs
testing weapons and showing that while
the guns are part printed plastic they
are not fragile
those who create and share firearm files
for free have thousands of followers on
twitter
youtube and instagram
from there they direct people to
literally google their way to guns
users are led to smaller social media
sites that hosts videos and other
content
a user can select the gun they want and
from there download the files needed to
print its components
this means it can take as little as
three clicks to go from youtube
to the hosting website to downloading
gun files for free
one popular printable firearm the fgc 9
has more than 70 000 hits on its
download page
rajam basra is a radicalization
researcher and has been closely
following the advent of printable guns
the 3d printed gun movement has its home
on the internet so it's strongly
influenced by internet culture it's full
of memes in jokes when they share their
videos online they're slickly edited
there's nice music the people presenting
it or from wearing balaclavas to hide
their true identity so there's a certain
cool factor to it alright let's do a
little more
matt laurizier helps design and
distribute these gun files
he sees these firearms as a matter of
freedom
there's no
3d guns incorporated there's no
ceo of 3d printing guns but i will tell
you the prevailing motivations that i've
seen of the people in our communities
is just a
incredible love of freedom in the people
and a understanding that we have the
right to bodily autonomy and the best
way to keep our bodies secure is to have
effective mechanisms to defend ourselves
mass shootings involving non-3d printed
guns like the school attack in uvalde
texas have reignited debate over ease of
access to firearms in the u.s
america's gun laws are relaxed in
comparison with most of europe where
firearms including printable ones are
illegal police are investigating two
printed guns in northern ireland
and these homemade firearms are turning
up on the streets of london police were
called by member of the public to what
they believed to be a firearm that was
contained in rucksack the metropolitan
police say they have recovered four
partially constructed 3d printed guns
since 2018.
sky news has been given exclusive access
to the force's work on tackling 3d
printed guns
which includes researching and printing
their own firearms you see as an example
of one that was printed here
one of the earlier designs the actual
barrel itself
has broken away from the weapon so it
demonstrates actually somebody might be
able to print one of these from a cad
file that they've taken online actually
it's it's their capabilities are not
consistent with what they would perhaps
want it to be
used for
there's a misconception that 3d printed
guns are entirely plastic
they tend to need some metal pieces a
printable version of this glock would
require
springs pins the barrel and other metal
parts
these parts can often be bought from
mainstream online superstores
but
different guns are more complex than
others for example a glock like this
would require a metal slider
among other additional metal elements
well i just don't want to give the
impression
that it's as easy as printing off a page
of a4 paper that's not the case you need
all of the correct components you need
the right designs you need to assemble
it correctly you need to test it with
ammunition which in the uk is not so
easy to come by and you need to prove
that it works and that it's reliable
since 2019 six people in the uk have
been prosecuted where 3d printed guns
played a role in their case
of them
five were linked to the far right i
wouldn't say the greatest risk comes
from the 3d printed gun movement on mass
radicalizing and carrying out
ideologically or politically motivated
violence i would say the greater risk
comes from
existing extremists
coming across these communities and due
to their lack security they can easily
join them download the right designs
and use them as they wish
in germany a neo-nazi killed two people
and attacked a synagogue in 2019
he wanted to show the power of 3d
printed guns and other improvised
weapons
the key point is will it inspire other
people to follow that same
attack method as we've seen with other
attack methods like vehicle rammings
stabbings and so on
stefan balliet in germany thought he
would be that person to inspire
a wave of copycat attacks but it wasn't
the case so in the future we may see
something similar like that by someone
who's dedicated to
proving the viability of a 3d printed
gun
so
do those who put these files online feel
any responsibility for where they end up
our only interest
is the freedom of human beings to
protect themselves
and frankly in our groups we have rules
where hateful
content like that hateful speech
disparagement of others especially based
on race is not tolerated currently 3d
printed guns make up only a fraction of
the met police's work with the force
seizing more than 500 firearms last year
alone
but how do you police something that can
be built behind closed doors so we're
training our staff to look out for guns
that aren't conventional it could be
brightly coloured it could look like a
toy
we need to understand the threat and
treat it as an emerging threat monitor
it monitor those people that are looking
at this online if we can
and intercept those weapons before they
hit the streets of london
enthusiasts in america will continue to
push the boundaries of 3d printed guns
but these homemade firearms remain rare
in the uk for now
a twitter spokesperson told sky news
that keeping people safe on twitter is a
top priority for us and it is against
our rules to use our service for any
illegal activities this includes the
selling buying or facilitating
transactions in illegal goods or
services as well as certain types of
regulated goods or services
we remain vigilant and take robust
enforcement action where we identify
violations of our rules
the accounts shared have been
permanently suspended for violating the
twitter rules on illegal or regulated
goods or services
instagram and youtube have removed
accounts which break their policies
which forbid content intended to
instruct users on how to construct 3d
printed guns
[Music]